[Music]
hello everyone i'm dennis boren master
resident and this is games you should
know by heart and today I'll start with
a question about chess dynasties can
anyone tell me some chess dynasties from
our rich culture called chess vulgare
yeah the Pagar sister is a famous chess
dynasty yeah the puzzles yeah
the fine gold in the Shahadah yeah
but can anyone mention dutch dynasties
here's a game from Arnold fun forest the
fun forest family and they're actually
extremely famous in dark circles but
let's take a look at this game first all
right
efore nothing really that's very normal
he for some move e5 Knight f3 knight c6
Bishop c4 Knight f6 d4 and I'm sad to
say no fried liver this time they're all
sad but Arnold fun forest plays d4 it
takes d4 castles Knight takes e4 how
should white continue here if I can ask
the audience
it's white to move yes that's correct
rook e1 d5 ha I'm a pawn up bishop d5
Queen takes d5 Knight c3 yeah this is
very very classical line there's no D
takes easy because Queen takes d5 Queen
h5 that's what's played Knight takes e4
Bishop e6 and now fun forest
Arnold fun forest finds a very good move
she's actually Bishop g5 stopping black
from castling h6 and now there's a very
brilliant move Bishop f6 yeah and
obviously man there's no G takes because
Knight takes f6 let's just show up and
then be part from the Queen and white
will be celebrating so green a5 and or
should I continue an ID for of course if
we sacrifice it once will sacrifice it
again Knight takes d4 G takes f6 so the
Gosselin was dropped but it's picked up
and now we sacrifice the piece we have
to show that you're worthy let's show
that me worthy not a question is how can
we break through in this position any
ideas yes
that ifs f 6 + f5 biking g7 mm-hmm yes
actually
Arnel phone forest did the reversed
order he took on e6 first I'm not sure
there's anything wrong with takes and
King G 796 king takes f6 would feel a
little chilly for the king
so not ye 6 was played so take c6 Knight
f6 7
Green d7 yes and he plays it so black
plays Bishop e7 but what if like decides
to take it
challenge accepted
okay rook takes and go but we have to
mate otherwise we'll just lose we have
to be precise and most likely its mate
the other way is h4 and just chase the
King around at this age for win
III and I go back to g5
mm-hmm yeah there's many ways so when
that's correct
yeah or wookie for checkers could be
also nice and here check Nate
that'd be cool but Alice it didn't
happen black played Bishop e7 green
takes King g7
95 very good move might realized that
yeah one thing cutting away the king
queen right cutting the Queen off from
the defensive also attacking the bishop
but white also realized that if he would
bring the rook it just lose too much
material you know so there's no Knight
h5 check because this Queen would just
do the duty of taking so Knight d5 rook
e8 Queen d7 setting up this threat of
taking on e7 means c5 know why plays
another very very precise move
mm-hmm rook rook III and rookie for I
would like book III as well
this looks good for white what he takes
first which is good we can see this
enormous pressure and there's night II 6
in the air there's 9 takes a 8 so black
plays Queen age 5 takes takes to
continue rook where
why already has a big attack but yeah
rookie three seems like a great move
yeah just just doubling well rookies we
compared to any other moves the thing is
on each be its stable and remember we
there's still kind of sacrificing
material so if those bishop and knight
could coordinate well black can put up a
fight so that's why it's good to put
your pieces where they're defended
that's five rookies we are not rookie
for King h8 okay II won and I love the
way
Arnold fun forest first puts his pieces
and the ideal squares then starts
munching on pawns Luke the eight
yum-yum-yum we see v h3 just creating a
little looked for the King so you can
run away on h2 later on okay a fate rook
takes e7 takes here takes and if I'm
counting correctly what has a lot of
pawns and black doesn't really have much
so
Fung Gelder resigned in this position
now how would you rate the white player
what would his rating be 2100 2300
mm-hmm 2400 okay
so my second question is when was this
game played was it sharply calculated by
white or not
I think yes definitely but in fact this
was played in 1918 and in this way I
would like to join the debate between
Josh Vidal and benjamin feingold and i'm
citing that just because it's played in
the 1918 arnold font Forrest who's
actually was three times dutch champion
wasn't a bad player he just laid it in
the 1900s that's all
and actually that means that talent is
ageless you can look up games from the
1900s the 1800s there could be games
that are on the highest level and I feel
in this game it was shown that Arnold
funk Forrest had the skills to bleep
play to play 2600 or 2650 and I feel
this was pretty close and so yes this
dynasty is the fun Forrest dynasty which
is actually from Holland I mean from
Dutch land I mean yeah from the
Netherlands thank you and font Forrest
Arnold is the great-great-grandfather of
Jordan font Forest which is amazing that
this is a chess dynasty that you've
never heard of in fact Arnold font
Forrest had a brother and I'm going to
show his games
and his name is dick Phan forest what
you should know about the Vaughn forest
of these times that both of them were
three times Dutch champions so they were
pretty great and in fact ever said about
Derek that if he didn't become a doctor
he would have become a world champion
and was also interesting a little bit of
an extra tidbit about the font forests
that they're Yonkers which XAR actually
means young masters so they're actually
the Lords of chess actually from a noble
family so let's start off with this game
efore e5 this was played recently in
1885 Knight f3 knight c6 and 1885 modern
chess d4 I think this is still pretty
viable he takes Knight takes d4 I think
this was played in London between
Nakamura and Qasim and so yeah Kasparov
- and Knight f6 was played in the
Kasparov carpet matches and also the
game Carlsen Nakano Nakamura calls them
the other way around but Bishop c5 is
also good move Bishop e3 Queen f6 c3
could we say that this is nothing of a
normal game
I don't think so this is very normal a
six now this is a bit sluggish but I I
guess we can give some
gifts from ten Holtz that he didn't know
that ninety ce7 is good here he was
afraid of night be five which is
understandable but by now we know it's
not a big thing they didn't have
computers as such a six and what moves
would you play here in this position
with light
it's your typical Scotch position it
does nice nice little scotch ideas 93
then that would leave this bishop
unprotected and would make a bad
structure so in fact Bishop c4
yeah bishop see that's what you wanted
to say yeah Bishop c4 is a very logical
move and played in many games but fun
forest Bishop e2 and I checked it it's
good there's nothing wrong with Bishop
e2 d6
Castle Knight d7 and fun forest finds a
move it's pretty good here
and remember font for us didn't know
about Moore's evich or anyone near him
not even tall he didn't even know who
tall this yeah he can you understand but
he didn't know so right found here an
idea
that would later become fantastic and
used in many games
but let me give you a hint now this
bishop it's a little bit loose because
we can't really develop the night
because the d4 Knight is hanging we
cannot really move the pawn because then
would loosen the bishop even more we
can't move the knight because the bishop
is shaky so if your bishop is shaky what
can you do to make a stable position for
yourself
before would just chase away the bishop
it's an idea but it wouldn't help the
stability of the bishop on a three-night
c2 is away and there's a second way that
they're fond forest found knight c6 is
not helping that Queen d2 exactly he
play King h1 first we should be Semin
now Queen d2 and this idea will be used
in the 2000s you know it's just a few
years away from 1885 and this is a very
good move by all standards super
grandmasters patzers everyone loves it I
do too I don't know I'm kind of
in-between so Queen d2 this actually
stabilizes the Bishop of e3 and the
knight on d4 and kind of hints at ideas
of 96 later on but with the intent to
take anything with the Queen h6f 496 and
we can already see that bite made a lot
of progress before but had only one pawn
in the center now he has two and black
can't really take on d4 let's say here C
takes d4 and white would just enjoy a
free Center for nothing and this is
possible because the Queen is well
placed on d2 and for example if castles
which is a very sluggish move then white
would be rewarded for waiting for so
long and not moving the night on b1 so
it could land on c3 and now white would
have a beautiful position and would most
likely be on its way to win at 496 and
now as we talked about there's one
problem left for white what is that
the night on b1 is still a bit geeky
it's just not good they're so fun first
realized that there is an issue there
you need to solve that somehow so he
comes up night a three would be edgy
because they'll just take it and we'll
have double pawns and we wouldn't want
that
before beef can repeat before then the
bishop moves away and we weaken our
structure a little bit so dick found an
amazing idea he's going to start a slow
maneuver just to achieve a good space
and good queen d3 queen d3 that's an
original idea good work that's not what
he played but it would give space for
the night
the only concern would be that it could
be in the way of Bishop b5 mainly so he
started with Bishop c4 queen d3 is
interesting too Bishop c4 Queen e7 and
now the signature of the fun forest
family the tactical site helped him so
he found a pretty good move here what
did he play here
'if I've would be a bit early might
still actually tries to develop more
you know that five then I'll take and
I'll take your bishop
I'm
1r5 that wouldn't help the development
for white so actually it's more like a
positional move with the tactical idea
it's definitely a queen move to mean F -
exactly
now don't dare take on e4 because you're
fairly underdeveloped for that kind of
adventure because I'll just bring out
all the beasts 92 bouquet e1 and there's
also this nice idea of takes and I have
this double threats and this sneaky
little rook will just attack your queen
in the end take stakes and we'll say
goodbye to your queen or your knight
so the e4 pawn is taboo and I really
like that from whites play that he first
plays for positional advantages and uses
tactical ideas to actually stabilize his
position castles and now what an ID -
and after three four moves white
stabilized his advantage and we can
clearly state that white is just much
better King h8 e five the idea works
because D takes e5 the Knight takes c6
and then takes takes takes takes and
white would be just a piece up
so he didn't take Bishop e6 now Bishop
e6 is a move that you wouldn't play if
you're happy with your position now
white goes on to punish it with very
normal sequence of moves but powerful
ones
and I think c6 and if I take back we see
we can wait I don't think that's wrong
but we should if he have a big advantage
we should try to increase it so I don't
know if double pawns are fun but our
triple pawns fun yeah so we realize that
it's just time to get some advantage and
those three pawns are not be happiest
how can we continue we already have upon
majority with white so if we use our
forces well enough we should be on our
way to victory
and five then I'll take on c4
and you will just drop the pawn on e5
chin
well whenever you're looking at the
position and there's still pieces not
ideally positioned what should we do
develop yes yeah okay you want chess is
simple just like that should be five
green g3 and slowly slowly black is
getting pushed off the board
Queen d8 f5 now it was already a sad
situation for black because there's no
f5 ideas because that would just drop
the piece on g6 and already f5 is coming
with full force
Queen d8 have 597 I should be continued
f6 of course 9 g6 and now dick phone
forest place very nice subtle little
powerful move he 6 that'd be a bit
aggressive I'm not saying it still could
be good but
age four that's not too subtle that
those are pretty aggressive moves this
is a subtle little move that Giri would
praise and this time I would agree with
him Bishop d3 yes so move there's no
need to rush
black is already in big trouble because
GF would just hastin the end and
otherwise black is out of moves and the
simple threat of Bishop takes g6 is just
deadly King gate seven and now we need
to go now come around this position he's
six is a way but there's easier ways to
deal with black
how can we just initialize our opponents
here H for justice and saying I know
that you want to defend your night but
she won't be there for long
King h8 h 5 takes and it's over 27 takes
Rena for F 3 F 7 and suspecting a mate
on 8 6 he resigned 10 Holt resigned I
really like this game because it showed
that indeed just because it was played
in the 1900s it was a very thoughtful
play by white wouldn't you agree
white had put a lot of effort to
stabilize his centre and also did his
best to mobilize all his pieces before
launching the final attack but there
were times he played imaginative chess
that's coming up next
so he's black in this game but don't
worry there'll be games that are kind of
new in chess and not all of them will be
from the 1800s and 1900s
so Bishop e5 and if we think eighteen
1880 what would we think black will play
in this position a 6 ok that's od6 yeah
d6 mostly that's very popular in that
time but what f5 that was played by dick
fun forest a very very aggressive move
with the intentions not too peaceful d3
Bishop c5 Castle the anus yes the 6 e
takes Bishop f5 and I admit that this is
a bit shake
he from our point of view but at that
time this is okay this would be suspect
in today's age because d4 would put this
opening structure into question but his
opponent was playing more timidly with
Bishop III Bishop b6 but I guess when
we're looking at players and their level
of play we should take a look how they
actually play chess opening is just one
part of the game yeah but yet he can run
our structure but what black gets for
exchange is the bishop pair so that's
kind of a compensation no it doesn't
collapse just because you have a doubled
pawn it's still a fluid game it's not
always that bad to have double bonds
especially if you have other pawns near
those double pawns yes
yeah he can but that would improve the
structure and that's what happens and
now it's not as bad because the problem
with doubled pawns that they get
isolated so you can chip away them and
attack them and no one can defend them
when there are pawns nearby it's not a
big deal to have doubled pawns yes age
three Knight f6 Knight c3 castles takes
takes C takes v6 now C takes v6 is also
a very good way of playing he says I
don't want double pawns
I just want a good structure and good
piece play 90 to 95 where is that night
headed there's that knight on d5 headed
to where f4 yes my g3 Bishop e6 d4 and
what did take from forest play here
Knight f4 yeah yeah someone with a
degree he knows that he needs to follow
his plans he takes d4 and d5 it's a very
nice sacrifice saying that this ePHI
pawn is worthless on that unlike my
attack Knight d4 and now Bishop takes
h3g takes h3 now should not xh3 King
Jeter
check King g1 Queen h4 yes
and then for dick phone for his feels
that there's enough compensation for the
given material why could he think that
way what's the reason he's so confident
about his compensation here that King is
loose also the white pieces are loose
the knight on d4 is a bit shaky this
night on g3 is not doing too much and
also black outweighs white in the
attacking Department there's three
pieces attacking and only one defending
this night is almost there but not quite
yet
Knight II - and like plays are very
confident and good move here what is
that
Ruki eight would be fine he chose screen
age three instead saying I'll exchange
these pieces but you'll activate my rook
for this exchange is in general when
you're attacking you don't want to
exchange too much but he felt that this
exchange is worth it
rook e1 how should we continue here
yeah okay f8 because is in general the
threats are bigger than the execution so
bringing some more fuel works in this
position rookie - it defends the f2 pawn
Oh gage for just queen h2 and queen
takes g3 is in the air so queen d3 is
played but if like okay if something
stupid then just check here and take
some white is just lost so queen d3 and
now black comes up with a very powerful
plan
rook g4 and h5 they're a little bit slow
there's no time for that
I guess the way dick from Forrest might
have thought about this position is the
following
what is the weakest point in whites
position the s do pawn and the square
how can black mount some pressure on
that square mean h2 and then that's what
he played now White has one move and
that's Queen III ruk f3 is an idea but
forest played an even better d4 no
because he could check on b3 and we
don't want that then no yeah probably
it's still good
rookie four very nice little move by
Dirk
there's no an ID for because just
checkmate
so queen d3 is only move green g5 just
take and I'll just take everything like
Queen g5 take take green f2 checkmate
look what rope rugby for well it doesn't
really do anything they're so rookie for
was good queen d3 it was basically near
their what
there's just simple win here that yeah
rook take C to just again known I take C
to cuz the same actually not the same
more simple It's Made in one so Queen
take c2 and Queen g3 he's six and after
d6 and white is just losing take cream
h3 green and hook up six and there's no
way that Brooke g6 could be defended so
dick from Forest 1 now I know that we've
seen a lot of games from the 19th
century so the theory is we say goodbye
to the 19th century come back to
something that people like more these
days and watch some games that are new
in chess and a game that is played by
Jordan font for us who's the great great
grandson of Arnold font forest and the
interesting tidbit about it is that
Jordan is also a dutch champion just
like his grandfather's and the brother
of Arnold dick so he for same-old
same-old we would say the whole family
plays e4 c6 d 4 D 5 92 now he's playing
the well-known Grandmaster Lommy are
then who played many times in becomes a
and as a very respected theoretical
Grand Master 92 takes takes Bishop a 593
Bishop g6
can anyone help me how the mainline goes
here h4 8 6 9 f3 97 h5 should be 7
bishop deeds me takes c6 we should be
296 so this is to be a position it's
very popular these days and obviously
whites and Jordan the youngest from the
previous ones
he knows his positions and he plays this
very very topical variation we should be
7 king b1 Luke c8 and in general what is
my playing for in this position
yeah white is trying to actually mount
an attack on black now black is hoping
to get some counter play for it so it's
white to move and even if you're
unfamiliar with this position try to
find a way to actually concern an attack
with white it's very useful to do
trainings like that 92 is away but it's
in some ways a little bit too timid
can anyone back there tell me how why
could play a very nice active aggressive
move
well white now that five is so so active
it gives away a piece so let's not get
too active like that not nineties yeah
naughty five it's an active move so
that's pretty good
c4 doesn't really help us to get things
going on the kingside
yeah so when when you can don't show
your intentions there for forest they
naughty for if you play rook g1 here you
give away the fact that you're trying to
make me so I'm not gonna Castle into
that and if you play 94 it's not quite a
parent yet what your intentions are and
in fact after castles there's one very
enterprising move and if you have a good
idea please raise your hand
yes
not EEG 5 but it wouldn't work now
because I take and here the night is
defending the age 7 square so it doesn't
really work but g4 is a good one
and now like we'll have a big attack
therefore Alami is being cautious and
finds a move that gives him some counter
play and doesn't get his king under an
attack anyone an idea please raise your
hand if you have an idea
yes mm-hmm that's the way taking getting
rid of all those pieces
what Alami was looking for some
counterplay in place c5 Knight f6 so
whenever your opponent tries to play
against you the priorities move so
Bishop takes f6 and now as the King is
no longer on the King side what needs to
change plans d5 so the young Jordan from
Forest tries to break through in the
center Queen b6 that's not blunder mate
let's play c3 c4 or should we bring our
queen
can you please raise your hand
yeah we need to should I liked the idea
Neetu is good and Queenie four is also
good and that's what fun for is played
and because the queen is very active
here and also it eyes the black King
while it can draw back to c2 at times
defending the white king he 5 Bishop III
so slowly but surely white is activating
his own pieces between d6 and now the
real part the real meat comes in the
wide starts a very nice maneuver in this
position you raise your head
at age 4 9208 what time a very good idea
but the phone forest did it from the
other way from d4 using the fact that
black can't take because it's a pending
now if not h4 he might take that's the
reason he didn't put but ultimately your
idea of going to f5 was correct Knight
d4 Knight c5 and now this would be a
blunder
unless white had a good move here
because black is threatening to win the
piece any reason yeah
Queen g4 and there's no way you can take
cuz I just take on see it and white is
just winning so black stops it now we
plank the knight on f5 which is a very
very good piece 93
and it's time to cash in you take the
pawn on g7 takes takes King e7 and we
talked about the older fun forest
tactical site we should find and take a
look if you're don't fund forest also
have a tactical site or not it's White's
to move and get an advantage it's a very
beautiful move
rook takes d3 I take back King d8 I was
a [ __ ] d8 then yeah that wins
yeah but rouga d3 is still not good
unfortunately because Queen at 5:00
there's that intermediate move of green
f5
what's the first thing we spot in this
position what is mostly unconvenient for
black can anybody help me what the e5
pawn and also the King on e7 is feeling
a little bit uncomfortable and we kind
of like the unwanted guests we want to
make it even more uncomfortable Bishop
h6 you can play Queen f5 or Queen d5
it's not over yet but Jordans move is
just crushing
we chop c4 check exactly
black took on c5 in the rook what if
Knight takes e5 Kenny please continue
yeah d6 yeah I'll take the pawn if you
take the pawn I can still cover up
little bits and try Oh what movies
there's d6 yeah these six works that's
true but in fact there's this yeah these
things doesn't work although it would be
a cute way of winning the King walks
away unfortunately but this would have
been a pretty beautiful mates have never
seen quite like that so in fact you're
right yeah Queen takes e5 is correct and
takes 96 check and takes and white just
wins on the spot sir rook takes e5 I
mean it takes h8 Queen f5 well even when
we're winning
we need to be careful yeah King a one
rook d5 Queen takes h6 what you're doing
quickly gobbles up some pawns but he's
also paying attention to black threats
because whenever you're winning there's
always a chance that there could be some
slight tricks that could bother you
later on Dean takes f2 and now you're
done found finds another very nice well
calculated defense being g5 check have
sex and how could might defend and also
improve his position at the same time
Queen d2 well he could have played Queen
d2 immediately predators fine but White
has a even better way of increasing the
advantage mm-hmm Benji so King g6 yes so
it's important to have sharp calculation
even if you're winning and that's just
what Jordan showed and has the sharp
calculation I guess maybe inherited from
Derek and Arnold
I think this tactical side does help him
and he actually wins the game very soon
Queen b6 he exchanges Queens and how
should we continues age six yeah if you
have a passed pawn just push it
gate seven locate six he doesn't blunder
night f2 Tricky's let's rotate six b5
Luke f19 f/4g 395
G for just putting even more pressure on
the position ging f7 g5 King g7 back and
black gave up realizing that there's no
hope because after act takes g5 rook
air-five wins and white will just take
all the pawns that was the games you
should know from the Lords of chess the
fun for his dynasty and I hope you
enjoyed this lesson
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]